herzlich willkommen zur zdf heute live
um 15 uhr 23 kam eine eilmeldung die wie
eine bombe einschlug deutschland setzt
vorerst das impfen mit dem impfstoff
astrazeneca aus das ist sehr
überraschend in der vergangenen woche
haben andere länder das impfen mit
astrazeneca ausgesetzt die
bundesregierung deutschland sagte nein
keinen grund zur panik alles in ordnung
die ema hat auch das impfen weiterhin
empfohlen insofern tatsächlich wie eine
bombe schlug diese nachricht ein und wir
der gesundheitsminister jens spahn hat
blitzschnell eine pressekonferenz
einberufen die genau vor einer stunde
begonnen hat und so hat er die
pressekonferenz begonnen mit folgender
erklärung aufgrund einer aktuellen
empfehlung des paul ehrlich instituts
setzt die bundesregierung die krone
impfung mit astra zyniker vorsorglich
aus hintergrund sind neu gemeldete fälle
von thrombosen der hier in wien die in
zeitlichem zusammenhang mit einer astra
zenica impfung stehen vor dem
hintergrund dieser neu gemeldeten fälle
hat das paul ehrlich institut heute die
lage neu bewertet und eine aussetzung
der impfungen sowie weitere
untersuchungen empfohlen
die europäische arzneimittelbehörde ema
wird jetzt entscheiden ob und wie sich
die neuen erkenntnisse auf die zulassung
des impfstoffes auswirken
die entscheidung heute zur aussetzung
betrifft sowohl erst als auch folge
impfung folge impfungen können nach
einer positiven entscheidung der ema
gegebenenfalls nachgeholt werden wenn
die wissenschaftlichen untersuchungen
abgeschlossen sind und die europäische
arzneimittelagentur entschieden hat kann
auch insgesamt über den fortgang und die
fortsetzung der impfungen entschieden
werden
tja diese erklärung diese aussetzung des
impfens mit astrazeneca wirft natürlich
viele fragen auf wenn sie fragen haben
einfach her damit wir wollen sie
natürlich versuchen zu beantworten und
haben da wissenschaftlicher hilfe
nämlich als gesprächspartner frau
professor ulrike protzer ich grüße sie
ganz herzlich grüße an
tu in münchen str si roboter was
bedeutet das ganze letzte woche hieß es
noch nein kein problem deutschland macht
weiter und jetzt auf einmal dieser
stoppt vorerst stopp und man sagt alles
müsse geprüft werden wie erklären sie
sich das wir haben ja unabhängige
behörden in deutschland das ist das paul
ehrlich institut das auch unabhängig von
der ehemals von der europäischen
arzneimittelbehörde arbeitet und die
sich diese dinge anschauen und die haben
offensichtlich jetzt für sich gesagt wir
haben so viele evidenz dass wir erstmal
stoppen sollten dass wir uns das ganze
in ruhe anschauen sollten und dann auf
wissenschaftlicher grundlage beurteilt
ist da was dran an diesem verdacht es
als patient diese nebenwirkung machen
kann oder ist dann nichts dran so wie
die briten das ja sagen die ja immerhin
schon 17 millionen menschen damit
geimpft haben und ja doch schon eine
erhebliche erfahrung vorweisen können
aber man muss das sicherlich ernst
nehmen wenn solche dinge auftreten frage
ist dann immer ist das ein zeitlicher
zusammenhang oder ist das eine mögliche
nebenwirkung und das müssen die behörden
jetzt klären
sie sprechen es an das ist eben die
frage ein kollege von ihnen sagt stadt
von einer kausalität ist er von einer
koinzidenz auszugehen also mehr zufall
als ursache clemens winter chefarzt an
der münchner klinik schwabing das ist
eben die frage dass es natürlich zu
nebenwirkungen kommt es irgendwie klar
und dass es irgendwelche fälle gibt auch
und die ema hat gerade letzte woche noch
gesagt nachdem dänemark gesagt hat wir
stoppen das ganze es hat einen todesfall
gegeben
in anderen ländern hat es auch schwere
verläufe vielleicht gegeben aber in sehr
geringer zahl und die ema hat gesagt da
ist kino indication vecsey nation
highscores dies conditions also die er
sagt es gibt keine klaren anzeichen dass
es eine kausalität gibt es hat die fälle
gegeben aber keine kausalität ist das
eine sache den jetzt die experten weiter
nachgehen müssen
ganz genau die große frage die jetzt da
steht ist es ein zufälliges
zusammentreffen von zwei ereignissen
nämlich diesen thromboembolien
ereignissen und der ja in zeitlichem
engen zeitraum stattgefunden impfung
oder gibt es irgend einen ursächlichen
zusammenhang
und das muss man jetzt einfach ganz
sauber aufarbeiten und muss man
überprüfen und dafür wie gesagt haben
wir in deutschland eben eine unabhängige
behörde das paul ehrlich institut die
auch unabhängig von der von der
europäischen arzneimittelbehörde
arbeiten und deswegen auch für sich
sagen können selbst wenn die e mail sagt
sie sehen kann hinweis können die sagen
medien möchten ist aber gern noch mal
überprüfen und ich denke es auch gut so
jetzt war die pressekonferenz um 16 uhr
vor einer stunde da habe ich vollständig
zugehört und jens spahn hat in dieser
pressekonferenz unter anderem gesagt es
gibt jetzt sieben berichtete fälle von
thrombosen in deutschland es hat bisher
mehr als 1,6 sogar fast 1,7 millionen
impfungen mit astrazeneca in deutschland
gegeben wenn sie das einfach mal
einordnen 7 berichtete fälle 1,6
millionen impfungen
man kann ja hingehen und sagen das ist
ja so verschwindend gering bei jedem
medikament wehrmann glücklich wenn man
so eine geringe zahl von fällen
nebenwirkungen todesfälle wie auch immer
hätte können sie das einordnen
das ist jetzt sicherlich eine geringe
zahl und das würde ja heißen es würde es
wäre auf jeden fall in unter 1 zu
hunderttausend fällen aber
nichtsdestotrotz muss man sich das jetzt
einfach anschauen die lage ich kann das
so von hier aus auch nicht beurteilen
ich habe nicht die ganzen einzeldaten
ich habe mich die ganzen wirklich
wissenschaftlichen berichte dazu die
bekommt das paul ehrlich institut die
bekommen dass von jeder nebenwirkungen
die berichtet wird von jedem impfstoff
und das ist die unabhängige kommission
die das dann überprüfen muss und auch
wird und die jetzt für sich entschieden
hat dafür brauchen sie erst mal zeit und
dazu möchten sie gerne dass die impfung
so lange ausgesetzt wird
ich denke das sollten sie eher
vernünftig ist verfahren
jetzt schreiben bereits einige user hier
muss ich angst haben wenn ich schon
geimpft bin was ganz was bedeutet das
ganze denn für die zweitimpfung denn es
ist so das muss man sich vor augen
halten dass rk ii hat die zahlen gesagt
mitgeteilt 1647 also wie gesagt mehr als
1,6 millionen deutsche bundesbürger sind
mit astrazeneca bereits zum ersten mal
geimpft allerdings nur 217 haben bisher
eine zweitimpfung gehalt erhalten
das heißt also 1,6 millionen deutsche
haben eine erste impfung stehen jetzt
auf einmal da wie sitze mit der zweite
impfung aus das ist eine gute frage also
erstmal das beruhigende alle die erst
kämpft sind und jetzt keine
komplikationen hatten die hatten keine
ja also das ist ja schon mal sehr
beruhigend für jeden einzelnen der die
impfung bekommen hat und ich glaube auch
wichtig zu wissen die frage wie wird es
jetzt weitergehen wird man mit dem
impfstoff weiterhelfen können kann ich
auch nicht beantworten das wird jetzt
das paul ehrlich institut untersuchen da
werden wir in 14 tagen schätze ich mal
oder vielleicht auch schon in der woche
die antwort zu wissen und war als die
antwort ist ja
dann hat das mit der impfung nichts zu
tun dann kann man ganz normal weiter m5
als die antwort ist nein dann ist
natürlich schon die frage wie kann diese
booster impfung aussehen und da gibt es
ja dann verschiedene möglichkeiten
das gute ist bei dem astra zenica
impfstoff hat man ja zwölf wochen zeit
bis die booster empfang passieren muss
das heißt man hat jetzt schon ein
bisschen zeit da wirklich rational
erstmal dran zu gehen sich die situation
anzuschauen zu bewerten und dann zu
entscheiden
falls dann die entscheidung wäre die
zweite impfung kann nicht durchgeführt
werden
oder jemand sagt auch für sich ich will
sie jetzt nicht dann bleibt ja immer
noch die möglichkeit mit einem der
anderen impfstoffe zu boostern und da
kommen dann natürlich theoretisch die em
arena impfstoffe also von bayern die
kreise oder auch von moderner in frage
die in deutschland zugelassen sind oder
eventuell auch der neue impfstoff von
der firma jansen der jetzt auch gerade
kürzlich noch zugelassen wurde
ob man die impfstoffe so einfach mischen
kann das muss man sich sinnvollerweise
oder idealerweise auch in
wissenschaftlichen studien anschauen
das heißt
beste wäre man würde jetzt sehr schnell
eine studie auf den weg bringen wo man
in einer gewissen anzahl von von
menschen die vielleicht in astrazeneca
im stoff schon bekommen haben jetzt
nochmal mit einem m rna impfstoff
postert sich anschaut wie gut ist das
verträglich und wie gut ist die
wirksamkeit und dann entscheidet ist das
ein guter weg oder wäre vielleicht der
weg der bessere dann in ganzen impfstoff
zu nehmen
dann wollen wir gemeinsam frau professor
prozess einfach mal hören denn diese
fraß der gesundheitsminister gesagt hat
denn diese frage natürlich wie sieht es
denn aus für diejenigen die bisher die
erste impfung bekommen haben und auf die
zweite mit astrazeneca warten die haben
die kollegin während der pressekonferenz
natürlich auch gestellt hören wir mal
was die antwort des gesundheitsministers
war die entscheidung heute ist eine
reine vorsichtsmaßnahme astra zyniker
wird in vielen ländern auf der welt
millionenfach verimpft
uns allen ist die tragweite dieser
entscheidung sehr bewusst und wir haben
uns diese entscheidung nicht leicht
gemacht aber für mich war immer klar das
ist eine fachliche entscheidung und
keine politische und daher folge ich
hier der empfehlung des
paul-ehrlich-instituts ihr traum einige
user wie sehr können wir denn dieser
wissenschaftlichen praxis trauern gibt
es vielleicht auch systemische fehler in
der praktischen wissenschaftlichen
arbeit um vom ideal abweicht lassen
miranda denn silvia schreibt das und
andere kommentieren sozusagen die
entscheidung heute street schreibt über
youtube vollkommen falsche entscheidung
die viele millionen mal wurde der
impfstoff verimpft wie viele menschen
werden denn stattdessen ankowitsch
sterben schaden der entscheidung der
schaden der entscheidung ist viel größer
als der nutzen wenn man das alles
zusammen sieht ist es natürlich hat
jeder so ein bisschen rechnen
jeder hat so ein bisschen recht dabei
ich glaube die nutzer können das
wahrscheinlich genauso wenig beurteilen
wie ich das beurteilen kann weil wir die
einsicht in die genauen daten und
verteufelt dieser nebenwirkung dieser
fälle die jetzt berichtet worden einfach
nicht haben und ich glaube schon dass
das paul ehrlich institut seine arbeit
da sehr ernst nimmt und hat sich in dem
fall jetzt über die ehemals entscheidung
hinweggesetzt und gesagt nein wir
stoppen jetzt hier erstmal schauen dass
das erst mal genau an das ist sicherlich
eine sicherheitsmaßnahme gar keine frage
aber ich glaube die woche die zwei
wochen sollte man sich jetzt zeit geben
sollte sich das genau anschauen und wenn
dann nicht kein zusammenhang besteht
dann ist ja überhaupt kein problem dann
kann man ja direkt weiter impfen wenn
ein zusammenhang besteht dann ist es
natürlich besser man hat jetzt ein stopp
gemacht und hat mich noch weitere
personen geimpft dann würde man sich
nachher sagen lassen müssen zurecht naja
warum habt ihr das getan
insofern ist es glaube ich eine sehr
rationale entscheidung und die datenlage
die dem zugrunde jetzt das vorliegt die
muss man sich einfach anschauen
jetzt muss man natürlich dazu sagen ich
habe ja noch mal die meldungen die ema
betonte nun in der vergangenen woche
dass die bisher verfügbaren
informationen zeigen dass die anzahl der
thromboembolien fälle bei geimpften
personen nicht höher sei als in der
allgemeinbevölkerung also auch impfen
hin und her es gibt nur thrombose fälle
bis zum zehnten märz schreibt die
ehemals 1 30 fälle von thromboembolien
fällen unter den fast fünf millionen
menschen gemeldet worden die bisher in
der eu mit dem astra zeneca im mittel
impfstoff geimpft worden sind 30 fälle
bei 5 millionen sozusagen eu-weit wenn
man so will was die ema schreibt der
bundesgesundheitsminister sagt in
deutschland 1,6 millionen impfungen
sieben fälle das ist sogar noch weniger
als was die ema hier als unbedenklich
eu-weit sie da gibt es natürlich auch
oder geldmarkt er eine auch kritisch
äußern und sagen warum jetzt auf einmal
der stopp das image von astrazeneca wird
weiter darunter leiden da gab es ja
schon einige probleme zuerst hieß es von
der stiko der ständigen impfkommission
unter 65-jährige sollten nur damit
geimpft werden über 65-jährigen nicht
später wurde das wieder aufgehoben
nachdem man festgestellt hat dann
wollten auf einmal viele jüngere auch
nicht mehr
astrazeneca haben wir haben
eine kritische stimme bereits sozusagen
eingefangen nämlich der spd
gesundheitsexperte und theologe
lauterbach sagt die entscheidung ist
seiner meinung nach falsch heute
jetzt wollten wir einfach mal schnell
rein hören
ich halte das für einen fehler
der impfstoff für das vertrauen
astrazeneca reduzieren dabei gibt es
keine neuen daten die den staub
rechtfertigen ich habe noch am
wochenende mit jens spahn geredet da
habe ich ihm geraten den impfstoff
weiter einzusetzen
so professor prozent was sagen sie wie
kommt der sinneswandel sozusagen beim
gesundheitsminister oder sie haben
völlig recht beim paul-ehrlich-institut
sozusagen über das wochenende
ich denke mal dass da zusätzliche fälle
dazugekommen sind wo man gesagt hat okay
jetzt hat man irgendwie die daten jetzt
will man sich das anschauen jetzt muss
man sich das auch anschauen und ich
glaube bei allem respekt vor allem
lauterbach den ich sehr schätze als arzt
übrigens es glaube ich kein biologe aber
er ist ein sehr erfahrener arzt
ich glaube auch er hat diese fälle weder
vorhersehen können noch den genauen
einblick dafür gibt es im unabhängige
behörden die das prüfen die dann ihre
prüfergebnisse der politik vorlegen und
die politik kann übrigens dann auch gar
nicht so einen impfstoff wieder zulassen
oder oder sagen das geht jetzt weiter
das muss die prüfbehörde machen und ich
glaube das ist auch gut so weil damit
ist der einfluss von außen also von
pharmafirmen von interessengruppen und
so einfach minimiert dafür gibt es dann
eben eine objektive einschätzung und
diese einschätzung hat eine konsequenz
und die konsequenz heißt wir machen
weiter oder wir machen nicht weiter aber
dass es dann eben basierende von der
prüfung wie halt sie ja auch jeden tag
jedes jahr bestimmte geräte warten
lassen müssen und da heißt auch danach
es geht weiter oder es geht eben nicht
weiter drauf ist davon zwar bei der
pressekonferenz war eben auch eine frage
was muss man denn jetzt irgendwie tun
derjenige der geimpft ist und der
gesundheitsminister sagte ja also wenn
es jetzt irgendwelche schweren
nebenwirkungen gibt das ganz genau
beobachten was würden sie jetzt jemanden
sagen als expertin der jetzt geben vorn
ist mit astrazeneca sollte der jetzt ein
genaues augenmerk darauf werfen wie
nebenwirkungen sind oder woran merke ich
eine thrombose das irgendwie noch
reagieren kann
ja also die nebenwirkungen sind in den
ersten tagen danach aufgetreten wenn die
impfung jetzt also dass ich fünf tage
oder eine woche her ist und ich hab nix
dann ist gut dann ist es glaube ich
vorbei das war das was ich vorhin auch
mal
dann können die allermeisten einfach
beruhigt sein denn die impfung jetzt
ganz kürzlich war also zwei drei vier
tage her war und ich habe zum beispiel
sehr starke kopfschmerzen oder ich
stelle fest
ich krieg plötzlich kleine kleine
blutungen auf der haut oder sowas dann
sollte ich schon in den arzt
verständigen meinem haus verständigen
dann im zentrum anrufen das würde man
auf jeden fall empfehlen
also das heißt dann würden sie auch
sagen diejenigen die 16 millionen die
schon astrazeneca bekommen haben wenn es
jetzt mehrere tage her ist dann braucht
man sich jetzt eigentlich nicht groß
gedanken machen sondern einfach mal
abwarten wie sie es gesagt haben es ist
ja auch jetzt keinen grund zur panik
zwölf wochen wäre sowieso die zeitspanne
bis die zweite impfung kommt also da
kann man ja noch herausfinden wie es
weitergehen soll eventuell wird auch die
ema wie der gesundheitsminister es
gesagt hat das ganze prüfen und das paul
ehrlich institut kann dann entscheiden
ob sozusagen wieder der grünes licht
gegeben wird also sagen sie kann man das
ganze einfach mal so beobachten
insgesamt würden sie aber schon sagen
die ganze diskussion um astrazeneca ist
das ganze problematisch dass das image
darunter leidet dass vielleicht das
alles wieder weitere hürden aufwirft
oder sagen sie das ist im grunde
genommen eine ganz normale sache die wir
auch bei anderen medikamenten können das
ist eine ganz normale sache die man auch
bei anderen medikamenten kennt und es
ist ja nicht nur das paul ehrlich
institut prüft es sind ja mehrere in
mehreren ländern ist ja ähnlich
entschieden worden auch da prüfen jetzt
die jeweiligen jeweiligen nationalen
arzneimittelbehörden und ich denke dann
da gibt es ein sehr sehr gutes netzwerk
der aus deutschland und aus den anderen
europäischen ländern
die werden sich dann kurz schließen in
der video schalte und werden sich
austauschen und werden da nicht so gar
nicht nur auf ihre eigenen bewertung
beruht sondern auf einem austausch mit
den anderen auf einer gesamtbewertung
bewohnt eine entscheidung fällen oder
empfehlen
und wie gesagt für diejenigen die das
jetzt schon bekommen haben und die
sozusagen durch ihre nebenwirkungen
durch sind für dieses ganze jetzt
gegessen
ja dann bedanken wir uns ganz herzlich
für die informationen und auch sozusagen
das beruhigende schlusswort von ihnen
aus münchen frau professor protzer ganz
ganz herzlichen dank für die zeit und
die informationen von der tu aus münchen
von ihnen vielen vielen dank
gerne so das war frau professor protzer
in münchen aber der wir uns ganz
herzlich bedanken nochmal und
zugeschaltet ist uns jetzt alle banerjee
in unserem hauptstadtstudio in berlin
denn das ganze hat ja sozusagen ja auch
eine gewisse politische brisanz haben
gerade schon darüber gesprochen es hat
ja schon ein hin und her gegeben mit
astrazeneca viele viele viele
diskussionen
die ständige impfkommission hatte gesagt
nein
über 65-jährige sollten nicht damit
geimpft werden dann haben viele gesagt
auch jüngere da muss ja was nicht
mitstimmen und ich lasse mich nicht
impfen das hat wochen gedauert bis dann
sozusagen das image wieder aufpoliert
wurde von politikern und die ständige
impfkommission gesagt hat nein auch über
65-jährige sollten sich damit impfen
lassen alles prima ist das jetzt ein
rückschlag ein herber schlag für die
impfstrategie in deutschland ja dass sie
zumindest zuerst mal so aus denn
astrazeneca war der impfstoff der auch
die das ganze im tempo beschleunigen
sollte da setzt man ja darauf dass man
diesen impfstoff dann flächendeckend an
die hausärzte geben kann der es
einfacher zu handhaben als die anderen
impfstoffe die schon auf dem markt waren
vorher und das ganze sollte dann eben
das durch impfen beschleunigen schon da
macht eine pause natürlich schon etwas
aus und man muss ja auch dazu sagen ist
es konterkariert auch so ein bisschen
das was wir in den letzten tagen gehört
haben olaf scholz hatte ja bei uns
letzte woche in der sendung gesagt naja
wartet mal ab bis bis juli haben wir
zehn millionen impfdosen
danach hat der bundes der
regierungssprecher auch noch nachgezogen
hat gesagt ja das könnte in etwa
hinkommen jens spahn hat auch gesagt ja
im laufe der monate zehn millionen
impfdosen zur verfügung stünden
wöchentlich muss ich jetzt gerade
überlegen habe ich gerade leider nicht
mehr im kopf müssen wir noch mal
nachgucken aber auf jeden fall war es
eine zahl die hier für aufregung gesorgt
hat doch alle gesagt haben kann das
stimmen aller
dann von seiten der bundesregierung
gesagt ja das kann stimmen und dann
schlägt so etwas eben doch sehr deutlich
ins kontor wenn man dann bei einem
großen impfstoff lieferanten erst mal
sagt wir setzen jetzt komplett aus das
ist die zeitliche komponente und dann
kommt natürlich eben die vertrauensfrage
noch hinzu und ich stelle mir vor dass
das einer der gründe sein könnte warum
man heute diese dieses aussetzen diese
prüfung noch mal veranlasst hat weil man
ja in der zwickmühle ist du hast das
gerade beschrieben es gab nicht
besonders großes vertrauen bei
astrazeneca aufgrund unterschiedlicher
informationen und dann zählt jetzt
natürlich umso mehr dass nicht noch neue
zweifel aufkommen und da hat sich ihren
sparen offensichtlich dazu entschieden
den paul ehrlich institut zu folgen der
empfehlung und zu sagen das testen wir
jetzt lieber ganz genau durch damit
nicht zusätzliche zweifel noch mal oben
drauf kommen
es ist natürlich ein schlag für ihn es
ist überraschend für uns
es ist vielleicht ärgerlich für leute
wie zum beispiel willi 1887 schreibe
über youtube was ist mit den menschen
die morgen impftermin hätten bekommen
die einen der beiden anderen stoffe oder
fällt der impftermin aus können wir
natürlich nicht genau sagen aber es ist
klar wer morgen vielleicht den
impftermin hat steht jetzt auf einmal da
hamburg hat sämtliche impftermine sofort
abgesagt das wird woanders nicht anders
sein und insofern derjenige sich
vielleicht gefreut hatte und gesagt ich
bin lehrer oder lehrerin und morgen
werde ich geimpft oder erzieherin
erzieherin in der kita und dann stehe
ich sicherer da wenn ich mit den kindern
bin ja astrazeneca ist da erst mal
zumindest mal für ein paar wochen vom
tisch haben es eben gehört es dauerte
ein bisschen bis man das ganze prüft
stefan es schreibt über youtube eine
hiobsbotschaft die nächste wenn ich noch
eine geile hätte dann würde sie mir
jetzt hochkommen
ja man hat es da wohl schwierigkeiten
und
nintendo kater schreibt über youtube
dieses ganze hin und her wird die
pandemie wohl verlängern sehr schade und
tod schreibt über youtube das image von
astra vom astra impfstoff ist damit
komplett zerstört egal was bei der
untersuchung rauskommt
das ist eine frage gewesen die ganz
sparen des öfteren gestellt worden ist
was bedeutet das denn wird denn selbst
wenn das paul-ehrlich-institut in zwei
wochen sagt ist doch alles unbedenklich
die prüfungen haben ergeben reine
zufälle
wer wird sich dann mit astrazeneca noch
impfen lassen ja er hat glaube ich
versucht heute in der pressekonferenz
schon ein bisschen dagegen zu halten und
den schaden zu begrenzen die in dem er
gesagt hat das ist eine vorsorgliche
maßnahme die große mehrheit derjenigen
die mit astrazeneca geimpft worden sind
und auch noch geimpft werden hat kein
risiko er sagt es gibt ein geringes
risiko dass man eben untersuchen muss
aber das ist natürlich die frage was
davon ankommt wenn ich als als derjenige
der sich impfen lassen soll höre es gibt
dieses risiko dann steht das natürlich
immer im hintergrund und natürlich kann
man dazu sagen und das tun jetzt auch
mehrere stimmen wir haben ja eben auch
die medizinerin gehört frau protzer die
gesagt hat dass das man das untersucht
und dass der schaden größer ist wenn man
nicht geimpft wird diese stimmen gibt es
auch aber es ist eben immer die
abwägungsfrage mit wie viel angst gehen
die leute dahin gehen sie dann überhaupt
noch hin und lassen sich damit impfen
und das ausgerechnet mit dem impfstoff
der sehr einfach zu verhelfen ist also
jetzt sparen versucht da schon
tatsächlich schadensbegrenzung verbal zu
betreiben aber dieser schritt wird das
vertrauen tatsächlich weiter untergraben
und ob man es dann irgendwann wieder
zurückholen kann das zeigt sich erst
wenn der stoff dann wieder auf dem markt
ist und wenn sich die menschen
entscheiden können lasse ich mich damit
impfen oder nicht
jetzt haben wir eben schon gesagt in der
pressekonferenz kamen natürlich viele
fragen stellvertretend von den
journalisten für viele bürger gestellt
die sich natürlich frage ich habe die
erste impfung wir haben schon gesagt 16
47 millionen deutsche sind mit
astrazeneca geimpft worden
du hast es gerade gesagt da ist ja die
hoffnung dass das impfen damit schneller
wird so und diese 1,6 4 7 millionen
fragen sich natürlich jetzt wie es was
ist eigentlich mit der zweiten impfung
und das hat der gesundheitsministerien
sparen dazu gesagt hör mir ein was jetzt
die impf ziele angeht was die zur
verfügung stehende dosen zahl an
impfstoffen angeht
das müssen wir uns jetzt in den nächsten
tagen anschauen eines ist ja wichtig wir
setzen aus um zu überprüfen
das ergebnis der überprüfung ist offen
und deswegen setzen wir jetzt eben
darauf dass die europäische
arzneimittelagentur idealerweise noch im
laufe dieser woche auch zu ihrer
entscheidung und ihrer empfehlung kommt
und wäre die entscheidung dann positiv
mit anderen worten dass es wieder grünes
licht gibt dass man mit astrazeneca
weiter impfen kann dann wäre es eben
kein problem wie wir ja eben gehört
haben dauert es sowieso zwölf wochen bis
die zweite impfung kommen sollte man
muss sich nur vor augen halten einfach
die ema sagt 5 millionen impfungen 30
fälle von thrombosen und der
gesundheitsminister sei es für
deutschland sind die zahlen mehr als 1,6
millionen sind geimpft worden und so hat
er es zumindest gesagt sieben berichtete
fälle
das ist natürlich äußerst wenig frank
und andreas gesagt der eine ist
beunruhigt wenn er hörte astrazeneca
wird gestoppt et cetera aber ich muss
sagen ich habe im bekanntenkreis meine
cousine ist mit astrazeneca als lehrerin
geimpft worden andere erzieher sind
gamespot im bekanntenkreis in cetera da
ist noch keiner tot umgefallen und was
soll ich jetzt die diebe werde ich jetzt
nicht anrufen sozusagen geht es dir noch
gut weil ich ja vielleicht liegen gehe
und sage mein gott wenn man dass man im
verhältnis stellt sind es doch
verschwindend geringe zahlen aber das
image tours gesagt das ist deutlich
angekratzt ja ich glaube das ganze feld
jetzt auch in eine zeit in der das
vertrauen in das corinna management
ohnehin angekratzt ist das haben wir in
den letzten wochen sehr deutlich
beobachten können wie die zahlen
zurückgegangen sind in umfragen
die bundesregierung gibt da momentan
kein sonderlich gutes bild ab es gibt
viele kritikpunkte was das impfen angeht
was das testen angeht genau da muss die
menschen eben auch betrifft und wo man
schneller in den alltag möglicherweise
zurückkehren könnte wenn alles
funktioniert und erhebt sich
da hebt sich möglicherweise der der
effekt der beruhigenden stimmen dann
auch wieder auf also es gibt tatsächlich
auch diejenigen das hatte ich gerade
eben ja schon erwähnt die sagen man muss
es medizinisch betrachtet wirklich ins
verhältnis stellen also du hast gerade
die zahlen genannt
katarina barley spd-europaabgeordnete
hat darauf hingewiesen dass wir als
menschen bei anderen medikamenten ganz
andere risiken in kauf nehmen und sie
trotzdem ist täglich anwenden sie sagte
als nannte als beispiel die
antibabypille und sagte da sind es bis
zu acht fällen von thrombosen auf
jeweils 10.000 also das ist eine ganz
andere größenordnung überhaupt nicht
vergleichbar mit dem worüber wir hier
jetzt reden aber es ist eben eine
besondere situation in der wir uns
befinden
wir setzen besondere hoffnung auf den
impfstoff und es ist eben ein neues
medikament also da gibt es auch noch
kein gewöhnungseffekt wir gucken ganz
genau hin was passiert wo da muss eben
alles zusammen passen und dann muss auch
die kommunikation passen und da richtet
sich heute auch wieder kritik gegen den
gesundheitsminister karl lauterbach
haben wir gerade eben schon gehört der
fdp-fraktionsvize hier aus dem bundestag
michael theurer sagt auch schon was soll
denn diese kehrtwende schon wieder das
könne man gar nicht verstehen die zahlen
würden das nicht hergeben
also da geht es auch wieder um die frage
kommunikation jens spahn hat in der
pressekonferenz betont ihm war jetzt
zunächst wichtig dass er dieses risiko
dass das paul-ehrlich-institut da sieht
ganz offen kommuniziert und das testen
lässt und dass man dann erst weitermacht
als dass er da jetzt noch mal selber
abwägt also offensichtlich ist er
mittlerweile auch in einer position in
der er sagt jetzt lieber maximale
transparenz denn die hat ja in den
letzten fällen gerade bei den masten er
gefehlt das wurde ihm vorgeworfen jetzt
transparenz und das wird ihm jetzt
gerade auch wieder kritisch vorbehalten
ja da sind wir genau bei dem punkt den
realos über youtube fragt oder anspricht
könnte diese meldung starke auswirkungen
auf die aktuelle regierung und die
koalition haben oder geht man davon aus
dass der bundesgesundheitsminister sogar
vom amt zurücktritt
es ist ja so dass jens spahn schon
sozusagen viel beschuss erlitten hat
abbekommen hat volle breitseite und du
sagst es ja selber egal was man nun
irgendwie macht tut man nichts wird
vielleicht dafür kritisiert nicht
vorsichtig genug zu sein
jetzt ist er vorsichtig transparent und
sagt das paul-ehrlich-institut hat das
entschieden ich folge dem rat der
experten und wir hören auf den rat
experten natürlich gehen andere eben hin
und sagen das ist der falsche schritt
weil es das image von astrazeneca
komplett zerstört also für den
gesundheitsminister wahrscheinlich eben
kein guter tag und der stuhl wackelt
vielleicht mehr oder wie schätzt du das
einfach ja der stuhl ist schon ganz
schön wackelig ob da noch mehr dazu
kommt ob das noch ein unterschied macht
das ist die frage
es gibt ja es gibt ja hier schon jetzt
seit einigen tagen eben diese frage
immer wieder kann er sich eigentlich
noch halten wie lange kann er sich noch
halten
aber es gibt keinen hinweis darauf dass
es wirklich pläne für eine
kabinettsumbildung gibt gerade heute hat
die union noch mal offensichtlich hinter
den kulissen sich darüber auch gedanken
gemacht nach dem wahlergebnis von
gestern
schaut man sich doch noch mal ganz
grundsätzlich an wo stehen wir
eigentlich und wie wollen wir eigentlich
die verbleibenden sechs monate bis zur
bundestagswahl nutzen um noch mal ein
anderes bild abzugeben
da gibt es sicherlich auch ideen
vielleicht noch mal mit einem anderen
anders zusammengestellten kabinett neue
punkte sammeln zu können aber es gibt
keinerlei hinweise darauf dass die
parteispitzen dass die regierungsspitzen
das auch tatsächlich mitmachen wollen
armin laschet hat sich dahingehend schon
geäußert und hat gesagt das ist jetzt
nicht nötig auch markus söder ist da
sehr zurückhaltend also diejenigen die
es dann anstoßen müssten sind
offensichtlich nicht dafür
man kann sich auch vorstellen dass für
die parteien damit ein großes risiko
auch verbunden ist denn immerhin nur
noch sechs monate bis zur bundestagswahl
wenn man da jetzt personal aus wechselt
heißt es ja nicht dass es automatisch
danach besser läuft kann auch schlechter
laufen der unterlage sagt es druck ist
da man schaut genau hin
und natürlich sind wir in deutschland
nicht allein auf der welt sondern die
bevölkerung alle schauen natürlich auch
wie andere länder reagieren es gibt eben
andere länder die
letzte woche reagiert haben und
beispielsweise um 16 uhr 30 also 30
minuten nach der pressekonferenz des
deutschen gesundheitsministers hat
frankreich auch erklärt und setzt die
impfung mit astrazeneca aus es ist
natürlich der druck den du geschrieben
hast der auf der bundesregierung lastet
auf dem gesundheitsminister kommt
natürlich auch ein bisschen daher wie
andere länder um uns herum reagieren
weil sie entscheidungen sie treffen und
das können wir uns jetzt mal auf einer
karte anschauen wie welches land unsere
nachbarn reagiert haben bisher in europa
sind die impfungen mit astra wenig
halten mehreren ländern vollständig
ausgesetzt
neben deutschland ist das zum beispiel
in italien frankreich der niederlande
oder etwa auch in norwegen der fall
teilweise ausgesetzt sind die impfung
das heißt etwa bestimmte charge in allen
drei baltischen staaten oder etwa auch
in österreich ja also man steht ja nicht
ganz alleine und wenn man natürlich
fragte lieber bundesgesundheitsminister
warum sagen die niederländer stopp warum
sagen die norweger stopp und wir nicht
das ist natürlich dann auch eine frage
die du hast es schon gesagt er dann
potenziell sich hätte stellen lassen
müssen wenn er heute nicht reagiert
hätte naja man kann es genauso gut
umgekehrt fragen und sagen was ist mit
all den anderen ländern die die weiter
impfen also die gibt es ja nun auch
astrazeneca hat noch mal darauf
verwiesen dass hier noch mal eine groß
angelegte studie gemacht haben mit 17
millionen geimpften in großbritannien
denn dort wird ja schon sehr sehr
fleißig mit astrazeneca geimpft und dass
sich daraus aus dieser studie eben kein
höheres risiko für thrombosen ergeben
hat das ist es ist eben momentan eine
frage wie geht die politik damit um
wie geht sie mit vertrauensbildung rum
was hält sie für die richtigen maßnahmen
bei vertrauensbildung also man kann sich
auch hinstellen als regierung und sagen
schaut euch die zahlen genauer an
das risiko ist aus medizinischer sicht
vertretbar und in jedem fall deutlich
geringer als das risiko an corona
krankenhaus darunter schwer zu leiden
oder sogar zu versterben
das ist auch eine strategie aber es gibt
eben länder und den hat deutschland sich
jetzt angestoßen angeschlossen die nicht
auf diese strategie setzen
so hast du das hervorragend zusammen
gefasst das ist der derzeitige stand
heute jetzt 17 39 und wir müssen einfach
abwarten wie es dann weitergeht was die
experten sagen das paul ehrlich institut
die et cetera und wir werden sie zu
hause auf dem laufenden halten chuck
unter vielen dank grüße nach berlin und
ich danke für ihr interesse ich hoffe
wir haben einige fragen beantworten
können mit zahlen auch wieder die
möglichkeit gegeben sich ihre meinung
eben zu bilden
vielen dank für ihr interesse tschüss
und auf wiedersehen